hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John
we're gonna watch something I'm really
looking forward to seeing word has it
mi6 trailer might drop on Superbowl
Sunday so you know we're gonna be doing
Super Bowl Sunday no watching the game
sitting around here once we start
filming one editing one another bubble
drop but today the footage of how Tom
Cruise broke his ankle while filming his
latest movie on that was I mean I'm
gonna run across and hit the side and
then call my that wasn't a mistake so
you're always meant to not land on the
roof okay so what you know you brought
us some footage I think this is so cool
to see this from the different angle
Oh see I'm wearing two wires they're
basically just safety wires because I go
to Full Tilt and I'm sprinting as hard
as I can and I hit beside the wall and
that's the stunt I mean I hit the side
of the wall and then I'm chasing after
Henry actually and towards an opposed to
run back okay so this is you see that
the speed and the momentum of the run
and it's in London there we go so it's
keeping me okay so
whoa what a shot this is from the side
here we go we showed oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
okay what's happened to this I knew I
broke two down I felt pain we got the
shots in the movie that profile shots
are you gonna run out oh that's so made
their vacation
[Laughter]
they're promoting this super-early yeah
I know I know for all four of the main
cast members I mean it's like being
ranges in there too but these four to be
there and to not have it even footage
out other than this what a professional
the fact that they like pull themself up
and move past camera - that's what I
thought that looks really painful
I heard she would be coming back by
didn't know for sure Rebecca Ferguson
would be coming back I actually do hear
Michelle Monaghan is coming back -
that's rad yeah they're making this an
actual full story that was six shot the
fall the tracking shot of him jumping
yeah that was a really sick shot yeah
this all looked like it was worth it it
was cool also just to get a glimpse into
you know what Tom Cruise the stunt work
looks like yeah we mostly see the like
one featurette before the movie comes
out and that did look very painful yeah
it looked like their ear too high or
something it's about time he injured
himself even sounds old in this video
this is the first time in a while where
I felt his agent the other sounds horses
voices to scratch or something or isn't
it good talking maybe he was doing like
a big shouting see yesterday or
something or maybe he's just getting
older because that tends to happen to a
man's voice when he gets that old that's
true he still looks great though
88 and Counting I can't wait to see this
movie dude I still think mi3 is probably
my favorite one but in terms of
entertainment just being an entertaining
film I think they just keep getting
better and my three was great ghost
Protocol topped it in entertainment and
they did what I thought was impossible
and topped that with rogue nation I
can't wait to see this and I'm really
hoping Henry Cavill does a great job
pretty mustache this better be worth it
say what you will about Tom Cruise but
he always gets me excited with one of
these when they come out and I always he
puts the the action into the movies
about time you got it
your buddy you need to slow down this is
a sign that wasn't even one of his
hardest stunts
mission possible sevens all gonna take
place in one room cuz that can't be like
the crazy giant stunt obviously gonna be
of giant stunts they promote they always
do that
part four was to buy part five was a lot
when he's doing the bike with no helmet
no helmet and that's the big one
I wonder what the giant stunt is that he
has to do the older he gets the crazier
the stuff yeah smart move Tommy
eventually he's gonna he really is gonna
die doing one of these stunts it's gonna
be like a like great
and then we CGI his face on some Norden
dude he is so that this timing yeah you
know we had a schedule to do a live that
joke even snook I wanted it took me a
second ago I think he just has the most
naturally fun interviews I saw that
interview I forgot I think he was on his
Colbert where he was talking about his
secrets you know having a group is smart
and also like having them have a couple
of drinks as smart - yeah loosens
everyone up oh yeah yeah
so that was masks it feels like a real
conversation instead of like an
interview feels like you're really
hanging out with these guys oh yeah I'm
four up new stuff paid for the day shot
Natalie Doran you know Natalie we always
do
our 100% authentic accurate Irish accent
for years we do but I'm not gonna do
that this time
when we Google hangout we often ask
about your dating life the guys that go
out in Ireland and ask you out at bars
pubs whatever doing your little drinking
adventures and whatnot and what I want
to tell you though is why we're giving
you a shadow on this because you're hot
you're gonna get a Tom Cruise kind of
guy one day he's gonna go run towards
you oh yeah we did that you're a busy
girl and it seems like once every two
weeks you post something about getting
drunk with your friends because that's
what the Irish do that's what you like
to do it's a good way to chill out after
the hard work you do all the time and
that's cool but I'm letting you know
right now one of the day what a dead
teddy
it's it's funny when I do it to you haha
I get offended one of these days you're
gonna find true love and it's gonna come
in the form of a famous white boy the
way you like yes fainted why you like
famous my voice and I hope one day you
get to make love to a beautiful white
man that you will find love while like
while you're making love you go WOW I'm
in love with this guy okay don't worry
it's not only the oxytocin spreading
through your brain that happens chemical
men have relations it is pure love we
should have just done the Irish accent
that would have been a more solid shout
out for you yeah yeah oh you're Linda
thanks for sending out our way you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bro get notified every time
one of our videos is up and we'll catch
you on the flippety-flip